bonsoir bienvenue en kiosque que votre
émission culturelle tout de suite le
sommaire cette exposition programmée
d'anne slacik au saint quentin en
yvelines du mois de décembre jusqu'au
mois de septembre 2015
six artistes exposent leurs oeuvres en
résonance à la ferme du mousseau
d'elancourt et puis à chronique de
nicolas gervais sera consacrée à un gros
câlin joie des 6 et 7 janvier au théâtre
de 50 ans ennuis il a rencontré paieront
cher bon voisin mais tout de suite place
à l'inviter à de ce kiosque anne slacik
et invité d'honneur c'est une artiste
associé pendant presque une année sur
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines à partir de cette exposition
différente qui ont vu dans cette lieu
également à différents bonsoir
ma première question c'est habituel ce
type de projet comme ça d' exposer cette
fois dans sept lieux différents et on le
rappelle des expositions tout différent
non je fais des expositions depuis 30
ans et je crois que là c'est tout à fait
exceptionnel
enfin je trouve que c'est un travail
important qui a été fait coordonner
cette ville autour de 7 projets avec une
artiste et c'est c'est vraiment quelque
chose d'important il unique c'est un
projet qui s'articule depuis ce dès ce
début décembre puisque vous expose en ce
moment la commanderie des templiers
jusqu'au mois de septembre 2015 en
différents lieux vous avez exposé à la
galerie le corbusier avec aiguilles en
cours la ferme du mousseau à elancourt
capacité tout est un site internet qui
va s'afficher mais comment vont
s'articuler les expositions sont pas
seulement des expositions de peinture y
aussi tout un travail qui est fait par
exemple autour de la poésie ou de la
danse
voilà en fait ça fait un an que j'ai
rencontré les équipes des lieux que j'ai
découvert les lieux et que des projets
ont été créés il s'agit de cette
exposition différente donc chacune un
projet spécifique au fil du travail en
fait des options se sont mises en place
en
dans le dialogue avec les équipes et
leur souhait aussi par exemple à
guyancourt
on a choisi à dans le grand lieu
d'exposition de d'évoquer la peinture et
la musique et on présente la un ensemble
de cette oeuvre qui s'appelle licht que
j'ai créée pour l'opéra de stockhausen
voilà qui seront présentés pour la
première fois avec l'écoutent de l'opéra
des fragments de l'opéra de stockhausen
et à cette occasion le conservatoire de
guyancourt a investi le projet des
élèves ont créé des oeuvres à partir de
ce travail là il ya tout un tissage
comme ça des conservatoires du réseau
local pareil à elancourt vous là juste
pour dire oui les dates du 18 mars au 3
mai et à la maison de la poésie qui est
tout à côté
voilà le vernissage sera sur les deux
lieux et il y aura une lecture de poésie
de trois femmes poètes avec lesquels
j'ai travaillé claude aubert ce fils
oiseaux et et et quitte à rots et avec
la vous parlez ce que je vous ai compris
qu avec la ferme du mousseau à elancourt
là c'est la danse là ce sera la danse je
participais à un workshop à l'invitation
de marie la vouvoie la directrice donc
j'ai rencontré les profs de l'école de
danse les prof d'arts plastiques et donc
je présente la huit très grandes
peintures de deux mètres par 3 qui
s'appelle la danse idéal des
constellations c'est un voilà un verre
de stéphane mallarmé peinture et poésie
et danse se mêlent et à cette occasion
il y aura un travail autour du poète
mallarmé mais aussi du rapport de la
peinture et de la danse
il ya possibilité aussi de vous
rencontrer il ya plusieurs ballades qui
sont organisées notamment vous serez
vous présente le 1er février 2015
allez quant à eux et amplis et là on
voit des extraits de vos oeuvres
justement qui sont exposées en ce moment
à la commanderie des templiers
il ya aussi une balade le 22 mars et une
autre le 6 mai la cie des spectateurs
prendre rendez vous c'est important
c'est toujours pour les spectateurs de
rencontrer des artistes mais aussi pour
l'artiste de rencontrer des visiteurs
bien sûr j'ai appelé ophélie félix qui a
coordonné l'ensemble de ces cette
exposition m'a demandé de trouver un mot
pour définir le projet donc j'ai
réfléchi et j'ai rappelé la présence au
pluriel parce que c'est la présence de
mon travail des oeuvres dans les sept
lieux et j'ai rajouté une phrase pour
voilà nourrir ce mou qui était un peu
sec comme ça c'est je suis là où je vois
c'est à dire que j'aurais j'aimerais ou
qu'au fil des expositions les gens face
aux oeuvres
voilà s'interroge sur ce qu'est le
regard sur la peinture prennent le temps
de regarder et qu'on creuse un peu cette
chose là qui est l'acte de regarder la
peinture de l'avoir est bon et je
dialogue
qu'est ce qui se passe justement est ce
qu'on peut nous parler de votre peinture
alors c'est une autre l'abstrait c'est
une peinture c'est ni abstrait ni
figurative moi j'aime bien la phrase de
mark rothko vous savez le peintre qui
disait la question c'est pas d'être
abstrait ou figuratif mais d'écarter les
bras et de respirer alors par exemple
lui ont souvent mal à perdre il est
temps pliait c'est ce qu'on va manger
j'ai créé huit toiles pour le lieu
inédite qui sont pendus dans l'espace de
l'exposition c'est eu un accrochage tout
à fait inédit
o fili félix m'avait demandé de
travailler sur la notion de paysage et
le projet a évolué donc je suis parti
d'une toile de cézanne dans le parc de
château noir qui se trouve au musée
d'orsay qui tue et ses huit toiles
contiennent la structure de la toile de
cézanne sous jacente et ensuite on était
rincé à l'huile à l'essence puisque je
brom et pigments c'est un travail de la
vie de glacis successifs et on a proposé
cette espèce de forêt dans l'espace de
la commanderie à l'intérieur duquel on
peut on peut circuler
on voit poser mais beaucoup les grands
formats nous en expose et d'ailleurs
vous avez plusieurs à l'occasion de
cette exposition pourquoi les grands
formats
on respire mieux de matisse disait un
mètre carré de bleu plus bleue qu'un
centimètre carré moi c'est une
respiration la grande peinture mais il y
aura aussi des petits formats à la
maison des bonheurs par exemple à magny
les hameaux en mai je fais je présente
un cabinet de curiosités avec 150 tout
petits formats ont été peints sur une
période en plus intervenu en 2004 les
évolutions de et puis au musée de port
royal des champs 25 solitaire qui sont
des oeuvres sur papier de moyen format
120 par 80 que j'ai vraiment créé pour
le lieu là aussi qui est un lieu qui
m'inspire beaucoup le lieu de la pensée
janséniste voilà donc à une rigueur
formelle de présentation des oeuvres à
partir dé philippe de champaigne et je
suis très heureuse de ce dispositif là
aussi comment vous allez chercher
justement l'inspiration
alors là en l'occurrence pour les dires
des expositions pour vous savez j'ai un
rapport à la peinture quotidien ça fait
20 ans que je vis de mon travail
complètement leur apport quotidien au
travail et l'atelier donc que je sois
inspiré ou pas que j'ai envie ou pas j'y
vais je suis dans l'atelier est bon
parfois le travail vient mais
l'inspiration elle est nourrie de
lecture de poésie en général d' écoute
musicale aussi et puis de ce rapport au
vide qui est là qui est on y met tout
son temps son énergie et donc le travail
vient quel est le message est ce qu'une
idée un message que vous souhaitez des
livres à travers vos oeuvres
vous laisser le spectateur libre moi je
pense que la lecture de l'oeuvre est
ouverte si les gens peuvent se laisser
émouvoir
ce lycéen peut aller à regarder puisque
bernard noël un poète avec qui j'ai
beaucoup travaillé a écrit voir et si
facile on en oublie qu'il s'agit d'un
acte donc essayer de se laisser
imprégner par les peintures de les
comprendre
se laisser envahir je fais des
rencontres déjà au vernissage là où les
gens étaient touchés voilà ça c'est si
si ça c'est atteint c'est formidable
c'est l'émotion où elle aime aussi vous
jurer 50 ans les motive aujourd'hui
merci beaucoup à sa fille il est revenu
sur le plateau de kiosques et je
rappelle donc il ya cette exposition qui
auront lieu à partir de ce mois de
décembre jusqu'au mois de septembre 2015
évidemment du coup les gens auront
largement le temps d'aller regarder vos
oeuvres cette expression dans sept lieux
différents et en ce moment vous exposez
à la commanderie des templiers
merci parce qu'elle est revenue en
plateau à l'est on va partir découvrir
une autre exposition c'est en ce moment
et jusqu'au 21 décembre à la galerie de
la ferme du mousseau à elancourt
l'exposition s'intitule résonance
projeter ses propres émotions à travers
des oeuvres très diverses présentée à la
galerie de la ferme du mousseau à
elancourt vidéo gravures peintures
sculptures la matière est certes
différentes mais le message est unique
ses oeuvres sont en résonance le titre
de l'exposition
cette année cette exposition a quand
même volonté que différents artistes
répondent à faire leur oeuvre
au-delà de l'aspect résonance des
oeuvres se raisonne aussi bien le mal et
le bien le blanc le gris le noir et le
blanc est donc on est capable de montrer
c'est ce que l'on veut ici que l'art
n'exprime pas seulement que le plaisir
et le bonheur
il exprime aussi des drames il exprime
aussi parce que ça fait partie de la vie
la mort dans ce cadre là nous avons des
artistes qui nous ont proposé des corps
mutilés
mais des corps mutilés comme un espoir
pour la suite
c'est six artistes ont été choisis après
une sélection via un jury une centaine
de dossiers a été reçu cette année parmi
eux
thibault la géraud 38 ans son atelier
dans les yvelines ses grandes toiles
colorées raconte des histoires
d'aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est de l'inspirer 2
d'image de photo reporters qui ont
traité de sujets que ça soit beaucoup
sur le thème de la liberté
donc je vous travaillez sur le printemps
arabe la syrie
je m'inspire de
plutôt de récits et j'essaye à travers
les récits écrits et les photos qui ont
été prises par l'egypte du photo
reporter de confier en fait sur une
toile multitude de sentiments et en fait
d'histoire l'actualité c'est donc le
nerf de la guerre pour cet artiste et
les couleurs chatoyantes pour mieux
masquer la noirceur des récits sur la
couleur je dirais que c'est venu petit à
petit le départ traille avec
relativement peu de couleurs très
chromatique des couleurs complémentaires
3 4 maximum et puis plus ça va plus les
sujets se complexifier plus j'en rajoute
plus le sujet dramatique plus
aujourd'hui je suis amené à faire des
toiles extrêmement colorés comme une
sorte d' équilibre entre le sujet de
fond et la forme
l'exposition résonances se tient
jusqu'au 21 décembre à la galerie de la
ferme du mousseau à elancourt
musique maintenant et plusieurs
rendez-vous fois a noté nous débutons ce
tour d'horizon avec le trompettiste
nicolas forme heures qui sera au prix
smile en cours ce vendredi soir à 21h
tarifs à partir de 9 euros
il viendra présenter son nouvel album or
ni ton qui un programme assez à groovy
pour cet artiste plein d'énergie un
extrait
et toujours au prisme mais cette fois
samedi soir tarifs à partir de 9 euros
pour voir eva selon gautriaud c'est du
jazz au féminin
un trio composé d'un violon d'un orgue
et d'une batterie autour de la
violoniste suisse et va selon go elle a
notamment été formé par didier lockwood
et un concert de noël maintenant avec le
groupe vocal cadran ce sera ce samedi à
20h30 au centre alfred de vigny voisins
le bretonneux
au programme bien sûr des chants de noël
et des oeuvres de brahms et de forêts
l'entrée est à 10 euros c'est gratuit
pour les moins de 10 ans un grand
classique maintenant le carnaval des
animaux de camille saint saëns qui sera
donné ce samedi à 18 heures à la ferme
de bel ébat de guyancourt tarif à partir
de 3 euros une vraie fantaisie
zoologique et je vous propose un extrait
justement du carnaval des animaux
c'est le signe qu'on vend temps et cela
forcément vous dire quelque chose
cette semaine dans sa chronique nicolas
gervais nous propose aux gros câlin qui
sera donnée les 6 et 7 janvier au
théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
elle s'empare du texte de romain gary
pour mettre en scène jean quentin
châtelain et son étrange relation avec
un python c'est un spectacle à voir les
6 et 7 janvier au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
dérangère bonvoisin nous parle de gros
câlins dans le kiosque c'est flou là non
lorsqu'en python s'enroule autour de
vous
auxerre bien fort rare talent les
épaules et à puce apple contre qu on va
fermer mesure où son tir tendrement tél
c'est une idée de frédéric franck le
directeur du théâtre de l'oeuvre de
d'avoir rassemblé d'une part gary gros
câlin l'adaptation thierry fortineau
joué par jean quentin châtelain et mis
en scène par mois frédéric voulait un
autre immense acteur pour deux pour
faire cette reprise mais il voulait une
autre mise en scène je rejuge de morue à
mon but on de joe ruban droit jeudi numa
c'est un livre extraordinaire
il ya quelqu'un qui a dit qu'on riait
aux larmes et qu'on est con pleurer de
rire en lisant ce livre mais c'est
exactement ce que ce que j'ai ressenti
l'idée que ça soit jean cantin qui
interprète ce personnage de ce monsieur
cousin qui va chercher un python en
afrique qui vit avec son piton parce
qu'il est en détresse ont besoin d'amour
là bas
elle débarque en cuir à mi cuisse elle
doit se dire qu'un homme de son tour
dans beat on recherche des êtres
exceptionnels
elle manque de confiance en elle même
c'est déjà écrit comme une fable une
farce et et en même temps c'est
prodigieusement émouvant alors qu'on est
mort de rire à chaque réplique à cause
du langage extraordinaire que que gary
invente gary dont c'est le premier livre
sous le nom de emile ajar
il ya deux versions du livre et sa très
peu de gens le savent il ya une version
que tout le monde connaît et puis il ya
une version où le dernier chapitre du
livre n'avait pas été publiés du vivant
de romain gary
il a été publié très récemment ce
monsieur qui vit avec son piton qui
amoureux de cette collègue à la fin dans
le chapitre inédit à la fin du livre
il est devenu lui le piton monsieur
cousin est devenu le python et c'est le
python qui va mettre monsieur cousin au
zoo donc le décor représente un lieu qui
soit en même temps 1 0
en même temps le deux pièces de monsieur
cousin elle tout de suite entre l'en
jugent du sujet en usant et votre python
vous l'avez toujours j'en ai eu le
souffle coupé personne ne m'a jamais
fait des avances
oui c'est une phase aussi sur la
solitude c'est hilarant et en même temps
c'est ont tout d'un coup on est saisi
aux larmes par oui ces deux solitudes
cette détresse de ce pauvre petit
bonhomme à la sempé comme dit jean
cantin tellement seul tellement
tellement malheureux il ya une
exubérance chez jean cantin et quand cet
épisode que je raconte est sûre quand le
piton va dans les toilettes du voisin
c'est un moment du spectacle à délire
absolu où il est absolument
il est génial tout le temps mais enfin
là c'est un moment inouï
j'ai refermé le bras autour de moi je
sais très fort cela veut dire qu'on
n'était pas contente son emploi vit
seule avec un python je voyais ça dans
mon dossier pour la mise en scène et
pour les lumières donc gg on a choisi
des lumières très chaude qui se mélange
avec des lumières très froide et que sur
1 cm dans la façon de bouger on soit
dans un comme dans un film fantastique
dans la façon de bouger de 2 jean
quentin c'est ce qu'on a beaucoup
travaillé aussi des fois on a
l'impression qu'il est dans sa salle de
bains dans un deux pièces et des fois on
se dit mais non c'est un animal
il ne s'agit pas seulement de tirer
votre épingle du g7 bouleversé tous les
rapports du jeu avec deuxième pas je
n'ai rien contre nay le prix laurent
terzieff et c'est le prix décerné par le
syndicat de la critique et on a eu le
prix de réserve qui le prix du meilleur
spectacle dans un théâtre privé
tout ça fait une belle histoire
et si vous êtes sages peut-être qu'elle
aussi elle vous fera un gros câlin on
retrouve catherine sur le plateau du
kiosque et comme tous les mercredis de
la chronique cinéphiles avec tout
d'abord vos avis de spectateurs éclairé
au micro d' elodie moi c'est un peu
différent de madagascar
voilà il y avait tout il y avait
l'action il y avait de l'humour je
trouve qu'elle est pas mal j'ai bien
aimé ça me rappelle les bandes dessinées
ma jeunesse je pense que c'est plus un
film pour enfants que pour un adulte
près 20 en fait un écart entre son
précesseur je trouvais que avec les
acteurs ils sont tout aussi impliqués
dans le monde donc je trouvais moi j'ai
passé un bon moment
je trouvais que il n'avait rien perdu de
leur superbe très bien très bon film
authentique et puis une bonne suite oui
joue à fond la carte de la nostalgie
puis on a l'impression qu'ils ont pallié
les acteurs donc là ça fait toujours
plaisir
c'est un film magnifique que je vais
revoir une deuxième fois j'ai bien aimé
j'ai trouvé très émouvant et drôle à la
fois l'humour caustique du prof de chant
etc
j'adorais voilà un film qui réconcilie
avec la famille simplement et puis non
vraiment je trouvais ça
très divertissant et puis très attention
et on passe maintenant au coup de coeur
d'un professionnel du septième art ce
soir cyril haddad des clayes-sous-bois
cette semaine notre coup de coeur et le
film français le père noël réalisé par
alexandre coffre avec tahar rahim
en cette nuit de noël antoine 6 ans n'a
qu'une idée en tête rencontrer le père
noël et faire un tour de traîneau avec
lui dans les étoiles
alors quand celui ci tombe par magie de
son balcon
antoine est trop émerveillé pourvoir ans
ce père noël un cambrioleurs déguisés
qui dérobe le bijou dans les
appartements des beaux quartiers et
malgré tous les efforts du père noël
pour se débarrasser d'un antoine
déterminés ils vont former alors radio
invraisemblable parcourant paris de toit
en toit chacun à la recherche de son
rêve
le père noël est un vent de fraîcheur
insufflé par un duo magique tarime
impeccable en père noël cambrioleurs et
victor kabel garçonnet au naturel
désarmant et un poil malicieux le
spectateur se laissera emporter par
cette jolie histoire pleine d'humour et
de fantaisie
le père noël et la comédie de saison qui
on chantera et touchera toutes les
générations
on en sortira et ce film est un bon
divertissement à découvrir en cette fin
d'année à l'espace philippe lauret
avec le cac 40
vous attendez quelque chose by d'or
débarque la table pour manger reste
focus avec ce film on ne verra plus le
père noël de la même façon à l'ailé
septième art également mise à l'honneur
à versailles à travers l'atelier
numérique
cela a démarré le 1er décembre et ça
prendra fin le 31 décembre
ateliers conférences au programme et
notamment une exposition sur le cinéma
indépendant en affiche jusqu'au 10
janvier également une soirée de
projection de courts métrages dimanche
21 décembre à 20h30 à l'occasion de
l'opération nationale le jour le plus
court et téléphiles s'associe également
à cette manifestation de courts métrages
en proposant une diffusion de huit
courts métrages entre le vendredi 19
décembre et le lundi 22 décembre voici
la bande annonce
et puis une dernière date d'agenda à
retenir le romancier eric reinhardt
l'auteur de l'amour et les forêts sera
en dédicace samedi 20 décembre à partir
de 16 heures la librairie le pavé du
canal à montigny le bretonneux
il assurera également une lecture avec
la comédienne fanny gilles et avant de
nous quitter à l'est un clin d'oeil au
site internet du kiosque il vient de
recevoir le label argent territoire
innovantes 2014
ce label national récompense le travail
initié pour la mise en place d'un
service d'information et de réservation
culturel unique à l'échelle d'un
territoire
un projet mené en cohésion avec les dix
salles de spectacles partenaire de saint
quentin en yvelines
félicitations donc aux auteurs du site
qu'est ce que c'est terminé pour cette
semaine on se rase quitté en danse avec
le spectacle des black blanc beur ce
mercredi soir à la merise de trappes
dans leur cadre de leurs 30 ans je vous
souhaite une excellente semaine et
gardait toujours l'esprit ouvert et
curieux